welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and black panther what kind of
forever is most shocking and mysterious
scene turned out to be one hidden right
under our noses from the very first
trailer a shot that in retrospect I
probably should have scrutinized more
because water shouldn't burn like that
in a country that runs everything on
vibranium instead of fossil fuels
spoiler won't even worry continue if you
haven't seen wakanda forever yet and
you're watching this video less than a
week of its release the spoiler blood is
on your hands so in wakanda Forever sure
he successfully synthesizes the
heart-shaped herb from the fibers of a
hemp bracelet given to her by no more
she consumes the fluid to enter the
ancestral plane where she sees
killmonger in a cameo that surprises us
and shuri yet something that killmonger
says shuri chose so how does this Choice
work exactly and what are the rules of
the ancestral plane when it comes to
t'challa Shari and killmonger and the
other afterlives being explored in the
MCU is that actually the ghost of
killmonger there or a construct in
shury's mind and are many of these
non-believers being plagued by the same
sentient evil let's first take a moment
to appreciate how well they hid
killmonger from us the very first teaser
in July 22 22 included a shot of Leticia
Wright in this ancestral plane throne
room with zero evidence of Michael B
Jordan nearby really the cleanest bfx
scrubbing that I've seen they likely
replaced him with empty red floor in
that shot that might be why the floor
doesn't have that cracked clay texture
that it normally does but I promise
there is a deeper significance to this
and why we didn't overthink it when we
first saw it so shuri takes the
liquified heart-shaped herb and
immediately begins to flash to images of
her mother Ramona's funeral Ramona's
death promoted protecting her when they
were exiled in the 2018 film but then
shuri wakes up underwater to the side of
the throne room floor the exact same
spot where Ramona's life ended sure he's
now wearing her White Funeral garments
the one she refused to burn earlier at
the Riverside campfire where she told
her mother if I sit here and think about
my brother for too long it won't be
these clothes I burn it will be the
world and everyone in it this is the
exact moment that shuri chose killmonger
to be her ancestral advisor killmonger's
Mo in the 2018 film was to use his
Vengeance to burn the world and everyone
in it or mostly everyone in it the image
tree of his tortion of the heart-shaped
herb garden visually parallels what
shuri sees now in this throne room it's
also what Rihanna's lyric refers to like
killmonger when he visited the ancestral
plane it was not the green velt that
t'challa described in Civil War and
visited when he entered the realm it was
a mirror construct of a real world
location with a glowing purple sky of
the ancestral plain outside where they
cannot reach it because they are Exiles
from that peaceful Kingdom instead what
they get is the exact location where
their parents died for sure it was a
flood water beside the throne for
killmonger it was his father's Oakland
apartment and this inversion is
underscored by the surreality of shuri's
clothes becoming magically dry when she
rises from the water and as she rounds
to the throne she sees killmonger and
call somebody's wakanda name in jadaka
and she asks how and he responds how is
never important as why right you chose
me and sure he says impossible I'd never
Choose You killmonger asks why did you
take the herb and sure he says to see my
family but killmonger says nah that's
[ __ ] you didn't believe the
ancestral plane was real did you and
sure he admits no the opening words
movie established shuri as a skeptic she
prayed whispering to herself in the
elevator bossed time is running out
please allow me to heal my brother of
this illness and I will never question
Your Existence again but at that
campfire Ramona had told her about the
Invisible Hand of t'challa guiding his
mother to this Riverside location for
the burning ritual she says I found your
brother in the breeze pushing me gently
but firm like his hand on my shoulder
and shuri responds he wasn't there
mother the breeze instead he felt was
just a construct of your mind so back in
the ancestral plain Throne Room shuri
admits that she took the heart-shaped
herb to just be strong and killmonger
says we're more alike than you think I
took it to avenge my ancestors too sure
he counters I'm nothing like you you
took it for yourself then destroyed the
rest unworthy King afraid of being
replaced just a coward and killmonger
says no I had the courage to do what was
necessary to change wakanda how many
people like your scientist and what kind
of protect before I took the throne
cowards those were the Panthers who came
before me before t'challa shuri charges
don't mention my brother you're the
reason why he's dead you burnt the Earth
left us with no protector then no more
struck killed my mother their blood is
on your hands and marker says nah that
ain't on me and don't you dare take that
away from your mother she sacrificed her
life to protect a girl from The Lost
tribe your father he was a hypocrite he
would have killed that girl [ __ ] he
killed his own brother t'challa he was
too Noble he let the man who murdered
your father live and here you stand are
you gonna be Noble like your brother or
take care of business like me sure he
does not answer this question she just
wakes up from it like a nightmare not
sure how she would have responded to
that question now before I continue I
want to thank this video sponsor inkbox
because black panther what kind of
forever forces us to wonder how long is
forever really like if I get a tattoo is
it gonna last until the end of time what
if I want a tattoo now but maybe not
later well that's where inkbox comes in
ink box tattoos last one to two weeks so
you can express yourself with a tattoo
for the mood that you are in right now
without worrying about whether or not
you'll want it well forever there are
over 10 000 tattoo designs to choose
from you can even create your own
totally unique tattoo easily using
inkbox's custom platform and if you're a
pro artist or an avid doodler you can
draw your own tattoo with one of
inkbox's freehand tattoo markers so they
come in these little packets here and
the one that I want to try is this
adorable boo-boo ghost tattoo ghost are
rad I just really like the design I'm
gonna put it like right here on my wrist
I think that's a good spot for it so
they give you this primer wipe you wipe
the area
white boy white and it's nice and dry
and primed as they say dealing it and
laziness okay it's now in my hand and
I'm just gonna let this sit we're gonna
let some time pass and then check back
in later after it's fully developed
because it takes about 24 hours for a
dark blue or black color depending on
what your skin is
okay some time has passed and uh check
it out I have ghostly ghostly pale skin
so it's you know it's like a dark blue
see unlike other temporary tattoos ink
boxes ink sinks into the top layer of
your skin and then after a week or two
it fades as your skin naturally
regenerates the ink is plant-based
cruelty free and water resistant and
here we are I've been ghosted in the
good way ink boxes tattoos are perfect
for switching up your style testing out
your next tattoo idea and make for
Unique gifts for the upcoming holiday
right now you can use the code new
Rockstar so you get 25 off your entire
ink box order and there's no minimum
order requirement but you can only use
it once so stock up the code will only
be good until the end of 2022 to get
started with inkbox just click the link
in the description to start browsing so
overall the wakanda forever film takes
shuri from a skeptic to a Believer
really this movie's answer to how we
mourn but the film does not force shuri
to adopt religious Dogma wholesale sure
you might be objectively correct and the
ancestral plane may still be a construct
of one's mind this being sure his own
subconscious rejecting the lessons that
she needs to to learn indeed there is
some irony to the trailer but it's
showing shuri in this room by herself
because she is in some respect talking
to herself killmonger a figment of her
own inner darkness and rage now Moon
Knight explored this concept of
subjective afterlives in the MCU
spiritual Realms that are formed by the
inner beliefs of the visitor of that
realm tawara it's confirmed that the
wakandan ancestral plain is part of the
same spiritual Network as the Egyptian
duat for Stephen Grant that afterlife
looked like a psychiatric hospital with
the glowing purple duot on the outside
of it for sure he and for killmonger
it's their parents death sites with the
glowing purple sky outside of those Mark
Spector made it all the way to the aru
the field of breeds which looks a lot
like the ancestral plane when t'challa
nearly dies these were the kingdoms that
shuri and killmonger were denied but in
Suri's Final Duel with no more as both
of them come close to dying from their
wounds of that fight they both mentally
returned to their respective spiritual
afterlife Visions for sure she finally
sees her mother ramonda in that
ancestral plain background who says show
him who you are so that leaves us with a
fascinating question is is it a mental
construct and we have all the answers we
need if we just listen to our inner
Angels or is the MCU saying that the
Invisible Hand is real from a place
beyond outside of ourselves the first
assumption means that shuri and
killmonger were blocked from the
Heavenly Kingdom by their own selfish
desires for vengeance but the second
assumes that like Ramona being led to
the river by t'challa's invisible hand
that there was a second invisible hand
that guided shuri down a dark path was
that hand that of killmonger himself I
mean think about it the MCU is now in a
place where love has both a physical
form and a definition as that which
perseveres to give us grief so the dark
hand that guided shuri could also be a
hand that guided killmong a darkness
that Ryan coogler might plan to name in
the upcoming ironheart series now if
that is a step too far for you I forgive
you but I do invite you self-empowered
humanists to ask yourselves do
characters in the MCU truly have free
will were they really own Destin paths
laid out for them by time Lords robots
and other Cosmic forces either way I
just love black panther wakanda forever
as a story that gives us a way to mourn
but leaves in our hands the choice over
how much Creed we assign to our grief
and I know you saw what I did there this
was my favorite scene of the film and I
want to know your thoughts and
interpretations on it comment down below
with all your thoughts you can follow me
on Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at EA
boss and subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]